ja vielleicht täusche ich mich aber man
hat wirklich das gefühl die groko plant
in der pandemie nur noch von woche zu
woche
man muss doch endlich mal weiter in die
zukunft gucken muss doch möglich sein
und auch die ganze ansprache an uns
bürger hatten auch jede menge luft nach
oben finde ich erst erzählt man uns was
vom kurzen november lockdown damit
weihnachten klappt jetzt heißt es ja
also lockern im dezember wie soll das
denn gehen alte regel nie was
versprechen was man nicht halten kann
und bitte mehr klartext hier der öh sie
macht es vor
meine eindringliche bitte für die
nächsten wochen ist treffen sie
niemanden treffen sie niemanden was
lustig klingt weil in österreich fast
alle geschäfte zu haben ausser die
waffen leben bei uns dagegen reden sie
immer noch in einer tour von weihnachten
ein thema dass millionen von menschen
ausschließt die mit dem fest gar nichts
am hut haben privatsache
wenn man kann jesus doch nicht verbieten
seinen geburtstag zu feiern
ernsthaft leute ich kann es nicht mehr
hören wenn wir jetzt vernünftig sind da
bin ich optimistisch das ist ein anderes
aber ein schönes weihnachten werden kann
dass das weihnachtsfest noch ein sehr
schönes werden kann dann ein entspanntes
weihnachtsfest feiern wir wollen am ende
ein schönes gemeinsames weihnacht seien
nachts weihnacht weihnachts
weihnachtsfest feiern aber
ehrlicherweise um weihnachten das
weihnachtsfest weniger sorge als das was
ein semester passieren könnte jetzt
kommt auch noch mit silvester mein gott
die böller verbotsdebatte der nächste
aufreger eine ewige abfolge von
drohungen und durchhalteparolen die
haben es ja verstanden die nächsten
monate werden scheiße ja botschaft
angekommen
und ja nur sieben prozent der
weihnachtsmärkte in deutschland so liest
man finden noch statt ich sage so what
mache ich mir hat meine eigenen
hol dir jetzt das komplette
weihnachtsmarkt paket für zu hause für
jeden zweiliter discounter glühwein als
rot gefärbtes terpentin mit melden aroma
absolut und trinkbare plörre plus das
original räuchermännchen aus dem
erzgebirge mit den drei typischen
weihnachtsmarkt aromen bratapfel
knoblauch pilzpfanne und natürlich kurze
und die drei stunden maxi-cd last
christmas in endlosschleife
weihnachtsmarkt für zu hause gut dass
jesus das nicht mehr erleben muss
reicht doch völlig oder die große frage
lautet wie motiviert man die bevölkerung
also uns für die nächsten dunklen monate
neuester versuch sind spots der
bundesregierung wie wohl vor allem junge
leute ansprechen sollen da erzählen
rentner aus der zukunft wie sie damals
also 2020 durch nichtstun die welt
gerettet haben
ich war gerade 22 geworden studierte
maschinenbau in chemnitz als die zweite
welle kann
wir tragen nichts absolut gar nichts war
faul wie die waschbären
ja gab direkt ein riesenschritt storm in
der waschbären community wie das heute
so läuft existenzsorgen werden verhöhnt
blablabla man nennt es ironie kennen
viele nicht was sich allerdings
tatsächlich kritisieren dem spot warum
sehen die opas im jahr 2070 exakt so aus
wie heute
das geht auch realistischer nichts
absolut gar nichts wären faul wie die
waschbären totaler quatsch
wieso waren foul das sind wir immer noch
das müsst ihr inzwischen lockdown 319
oder 320 seien keine ahnung weil der
regierung hat bis heute keine krone
strategie eingefallen ist warum haben
wir damals den söder als kanzler gewählt
haben sie da alle besoffen
im jahr 2070 ist nichts besser geworden
so husemann und im jahr 2020 gehen wir
jetzt mal schön zu den anderen in den
speisesaal was
wir haben 2070 und ich bin ein corona
hält absolut sind sie ein held und hat
erhält heute schon groß gemacht
viel besser bis jetzt ist die akzeptanz
der korona maßnahmen in der deutschen
bevölkerung immer noch erstaunlich hoch
trotzdem muss die regierung dringend an
ihrer kommunikationsstrategie arbeiten
wir schalten live ins bundespresseamts
matthias matschke
er leitet dort die abteilung für corona
marketing matschke wäre jetzt nicht mal
zeit für klare ansagen wie treffen sie
niemanden nein
haben wir doch alles versucht ich hatte
hier eine fertige kampagne wir wollten
drei millionen plakate in allen kitas
aufhängen weihnachten fällt aus dieses
jahr kommt knecht corona mit der erosion
route nicht gut getestet 300 kinder
mussten zum psychologen zu viel
ehrlichkeit ist auch nicht die lösung ja
aber die bürger sind ja nicht doof
die kriegen ja mit was passiert und
stellen sich fragen und genau dafür
hatte die groko gerade ihren
traditionellen tag der offenen tür
diesmal halt virtuell
da konnten die bürger die kanzlerin und
ihre minister alles fragen was ihnen auf
den nägeln brennt also klar gab es dann
eine vorauswahl wir haben dann nur die
besten kritischen fragen genau fragen
wie wie sieht ein typischer
arbeitsalltag als
bundeswirtschaftsminister aus ja das ist
eine ganz spannende frage hast so eine
verdammt spannende frage und die antwort
ist sogar noch spannender
ich stehe meistens so gegen 6 uhr
morgens auf bereite mich dann bei einem
kurzen frühstück auf meine tägliche
arbeit vor
und sobald die ministerium bin gibt es
einen enormen bedarf an entscheidungen
ja sag bloß er steht auf frühstück geht
zur arbeit und da gibt es dann arbeit
habe ich das richtig verstanden
machen sie sich mal nicht so lustig
viele wissen das gar nicht also ich
kapiere ja dass man die fragen von den
irren rausfiltern sowas wie kaufen sie
ihr kinder blut im selben geschäft wie
bill gates klar aber was da bei euch
übrig blieb am ende das war teilweise
echt erbärmlich
die ist der alltag als kanzler
gestaltet ja wir kombinieren sie job und
familie
wie hat sich ihr arbeitsalltag durch die
korona pandemie verändert ja er hat sich
ganz gewaltig verändert wie kommen sie
eigentlich auch mal zur ruhe
jetzt kommt die große sinnfrage
verstehen sie den sinn aller
steuergesetze und machen sie ihre
steuererklärung selbst so war doch gut
gekontert naja haut der scholzomat so
aus die alte spaßkanone und die merkel
brave fragen beantwortet von azubis die
die industrie- und handelskammer vorher
gecastet hat was hat das denn mit
bürgerdialog zu tun
wir werden ganz andere fragen
eingefallen zum beispiel warum heißen
eure corona november hilfen november
hilfen wenn die gar nicht im november
kommen
mein gott ist halt ein name in kinder
schokolade sind auch keine kinder drin
im übrigen einer frau doktor merkel muss
man gar keine fragen stellen steht den
azubis fragen haben sie schon mal
gekocht für die anderen ständig so
kochen hat deutschland in deutschland
müssen die männer auch kochen sonst wird
man abgeschoben männer müssen kochen
kommt nächste woche ins neue
ermächtigungsgesetz toll wie wärs denn
mal mit wichtigen fragen zb wie kann man
als regierung den bürgern erzählen
wochenlang zug fahren und corona absolut
kein problem
und dann kommt raus diese woche
angestellte des bundes kriegen einen
zweiten leeren platz neben sich bezahlt
damit sie nicht so nah an verseuchten
göbel sitzen ein pr-desaster herweck ich
finde es richtig gut dass sie das
ansprechen und da gehe ich auch gleich
ausführlich darauf ein
nach dieser bürger frage die mich in der
sekunde per twitter erreicht da fragt
eine
petra altmüller den peter altmaier gen
rotweinflecken wirklich mit salz raus
liebe petra das ist eine sehr
eine frage nein ist sie nicht matthias
matschke
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
mimen ersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen
scheiß und liegt - wollt dann abonniert
jetzt den kanal
was zur hölle ist ein minimal hersteller
[Musik]